Amy this is my sister Becky Becky guys
what you were literally yelling right
now you're you're screaming and there's
no one else here yet hey Maddie that new
guy Brian I think thinks I'm into him
which is weird because he knows I have a
boyfriend
he probably misread your intensity
meeting you it was so great yeah
so no no we see you again soon it was
super great meeting you
[ __ ] how baby how can he like her he
doesn't even know doesn't he remind you
though of it
I can't are we having a movie night if
we can't even talk you watching this by
yourself at home if you wanted to sit in
silence okay so I think what we need to
do numbers are a little low we need to
well you know Mia greatest a new
business centers remark being said it's
gonna be an awful idea what is what
someone would think and then realize
that it was a great idea and then
realized it was a great I was kidding
I'm so excited for this movie Saturday
night oh my gosh she's so good I still
got a family disease in mind I can't
wait for the party Saturday night I'm
gonna introduce you to Chad
yes mmm I mostly just work with Excel
doing some spreadsheet stuff I'm really
kind of a night bad you're so tired of
this conversation end
all right the minute there's silence
just let it be and get out no matter how
awkward it is but I mean you don't worry
about that no tell me more Oh Oh God so
this is your fault you're never leaving
I love you so much
shut up I'm just saying she's not a
well-written female character now a
champion
you